when a minister lies
they should correct the record and
presume you agree
of course and they might do so
inadvertently
that's the general assumption of how we
do our business in parliament that no
minister deliberately lies though there
have been occasions in our history when
that that has happened and the minister
has been
forced to resign it seems that you
very rarely correct the record
why is that i think i think i'm going to
need
you to give me chapter and verse there
as they say
i think there are plenty of instances
where where um the
the you have been told by
various independent and outside bodies
that the the
precise words that you've used have not
been
the full um and accurate version of
events
did you sack matt hancock well let me
let me we continue at this point uh did
you set that anchor
let me give you an example uh of the 300
million pounds a week
this was a um a figure that related to
the
gross sum that the uk
gave to the eu budget it was uh another
subject of lively controversy during the
referendum campaign five years ago as
you remember
uh actually it turned out if anything uh
suburb to be a slight underestimate and
by uh
this year the the growth figure
on on your question about mr hancock the
former health secretary
let me just go back to what i said uh
many many times and
i think i said on the floor of the house
of commons uh which was that
we read about and you know you read
about we all read about
the story concerning mr hancock and
uh and and cctv
and so forth on i think the friday
and we had a new health secretary on the
saturday
and considering that we are in the
middle of a global pandemic
and it's quite a thing to move your
health secretary uh mr bryant i think
that was quite
fast going if i may say so that's all i
have to say on that matter
that you said you said you've had your
time i'm sorry
thank you very much